All right guys in this video we in this lecture you could say we are going to learn about
SMT divergence and how you can trade with SMT divergence or you could you know add SMT
divergence in other trading strategies as a confluence okay so we're going to trade SMT
divergence or you could say smart money technique divergence all right this is a very very powerful
tool that you can use and it's going to increase your wind rate by a lot you know you can use it as
as a single strategy by by its own like you could use this single thing by its own and you
you will be shocked right or you could add this as a confluence with other strategies and it's
going to work perfectly fine as well so what is an SMT or sorry SMT divergence or you could say
smart money technique divergence so for this strategy you need two or three correlated pairs
okay the pairs or assets or instruments that have similar movements they have correlation
between each other right so for example Bitcoin right BTC and Ethereum they have similar movements
right if Bitcoin is going up Ethereum should be going up as well if Bitcoin is going down
Ethereum should be going down then we have NAS100 S and P500 and US30 right so these three pairs
have similar movement as well now for Forex you could use you know your USD GBP USD
AUD USD with dollar index DXY right sorry USDX now what is DXY it is a you know dollar index
it shows the strength of a dollar right so so you can use like Bitcoin and Ethereum they have
correlation NAS100 S and P500 and US30 you can use your USD GBP USD AUD USD with right so you
don't want to use your USD GBP USD right together you don't want to use your USD GBP USD or AUD USD
together you want to use one of these with DXY dollar index okay and yeah you can just simply
trade with these instruments and pairs and assets so let's talk about what SMT divergence
is in detail okay so let's assume that
let me draw this out first
right so this right here let's assume that this is S and P500 okay
okay and this is NAS100 cool so notice this right on SMP 500 we have higher high high low
higher high high high high right on NAS100 we have higher high high high low higher high high low
and then NAS100 fails to create another higher high so I would repeat it again on SMP 500 we have
higher high high low higher high high high high and on NAS100 we have higher high high high low
higher high high low and then NAS100 failed to create a higher high whereas SMP managed to create
another higher high so what does this tell us
this right here for me personally is a liquidity sweep right this right here why
because on NAS100 price couldn't make a higher high what does that tell me it tells me that the
autoflow has shifted into a bearish trend and this right here is a liquidity sweep
all right why because NAS100 could not make another higher high but this SMP 500 did actually
create a higher high this tells me there was a liquidity sweep so now what we can do is let's
suppose that you are looking at SMP divergence on a 15 minute time frame once you have the
liquidity sweep right and you see that the other asset or peer could not make a higher high
and this peer let's say made a higher high you drop down to the one minute time frame if you're
looking at at a 15 minute time frame you drop down to one minute time from after liquidity sweep
you wait for market structure shift and you take your entry from the extreme variability gap
it's really that simple so you can see that SMP 500 managed to create a higher high but on NAS100
we could not make a higher high which tells us that the autoflow has shifted into a what into a
bearish trend you want to trade the peer or asset or instrument that has swept the liquidity
right you do not want to trade this you can trade it because the movement is going to be the same
okay so if NAS is going down this should go down as well but I recommend that you trade the peer
or asset that sweeps the liquidity because you are going to get a better risk reward entry
so in a bearish scenario let me move this we have let's suppose
lower low lower high lower high and lower low right and on NAS100 we have lower low
lower high lower low lower high and then we fail to create another lower low
so right here we have divergence SMT divergence all right SMP 500 managed to create a lower low
but on NAS100 we could not create a lower low so what does that tell us what does that tell us
according to marbles all right so it shows that the autoflow or the momentum has now shifted
into a bullish trend okay so we they'd create a lower low on SMP 500 but we could not create it
on NAS100 or similarly if you just switch these pairs right like this or sorry assets
it doesn't matter all right you can trade any one of these pairs you should trade any one of
the pairs or assets that sweep the liquidity right so let me put this here just so you don't
get confused so once you see that NAS100 or any other asset or pair has failed to create a lower
lower lower high you then wait for liquidity sweep on SMP 500 or any other pair or asset that
you're looking at and then you trade that pair or asset that swept the liquidity after the liquidity
sweep you look for mark structure shift on a smaller time frame and then you take your entry
from the extreme family gap or autoblock so i will try to give you guys some examples and i'll
also give you some techniques that you can use with this strategy to increase the wind rate
all right guys so here is example number one i'm looking at your USD and dollar index so when you
for specifically for dollar index when you are going to put it out on your chart it's going to
look like this it's going to be inverted unlike Bitcoin ethereum NAS100 and SMP 500 or any other
correlated pair all right so if you don't want to get confused what you can do is press alt plus
i okay alt plus i on your keyboard and it's going to flip the chart upside down and then
it's just going to make it's it's it's just one confused you anymore so here is an example we
took this trade in the community as well if you're watching it i shaded in the mentors chart channel
of the discord so what did i see here right so as you can see on the euro USD we had this high
rate and we created a higher high higher low and then this right here this right here right
is a liquidity sweep however if you look at it here price did not manage to break this high
right it did not manage to break this high here so what does this tell us now this tells us two
things right that the auto flow has now switched into a bearish trend and over here what you can
see is we have a liquidity sweep right so once you have a liquidity sweep what you can do now is you
can go back to the one minute time frame on your USD right after liquidity sweep and you wait for
market structure shift simple as that so right here what we have is a market structure shift
also we have this structure break right so we have a break of structure as well this right here is
an extreme ferrability gap level that you can look for for an entry you can take your entry
from this extreme ferrability gap put your stop maybe above the first candle of the ferrability
gap or maybe above here just to be on the safe side and i remember we targeted this
and this low here but we could have targeted this level here as well because this is an ABC
formation and on the ABC strategy as we know we target this level as our take profit so if i
play this through you can see that we got our entry right and if i play this through you can see
just because we knew the intraday bias we knew that the auto flow has shifted on you know the
dollar and we knew that um the your USD has swept the liquidity we took this entry and
look at that beautiful move this is like textbook example of this strategy or technique that you
can use in your trading so right here i use this technique with ABC strategy you can use it
as a standalone strategy as well and it's going to work perfectly fine it doesn't have to be
combined with any other strategy it can work just absolutely fine but please keep that in mind
i can give you the best strategy in the world and it will not work for you if you are not going to
back test it i want it's just not simple forex it's not simple gas trading is not that simple okay
yeah the strategies that i'm teaching you are simple but they require back testing okay
they're not just like you're going to start using them on a real chart right now and you're
going to make profits no yeah maybe if you get lucky but if you don't know the movement right if
you don't know your peer if you don't know the asset that you are trading you don't know the
movement of of that asset all right you're going to fail tremendously so back testing is a must
at least test 100 times for your own sake okay so this was a perfect example we got 6.81
and notice that we are in a new york session around here right so make sure your entries are
during kill zones or you know a new york session preferably you can trade out in a London session
as well make sure you don't trade Asian all right it's just not reliable for me i mean it can work
for you but it's just not for me so i only trade London and New York so this was an example number
one we used your USD and dollar index now similarly if you if you have a liquidity sweep right and
let's say you have a liquidity sweep on bitcoin and you don't have a liquidity sweep on ethereum
it's just and the ethereum is telling you that the autoflow has shifted in a bearish trend you
can trade ethereum as well because ethereum is now a weaker or you could say weaker in terms of bullish
right in terms of bullishness so you can trade that pair as well instead of the one that swept
the liquidity but notice that how we got a greater risk reward ratio because we traded the
pair that swept the liquidity so i hope that clears that doubt so let me move on to the next
example all right this example is for crypto bros right so we are looking at bitcoin and ethereum
smt divergence here so on bitcoin you can see we have a higher high right we have a higher high
higher low and then we have a liquidity sweep right but over here you can see if we may hear
from this candle right you can see that price failed to break the high of this candle and also
this high right so this clearly shows us that the autoflow has shifted into a bearish trend
after the liquidity sweep you can see that the candle that sweeps the liquidity you want to point
your cursor towards that candle and you see if it has swept the high on ethereum as well in this
example it has not right so after the liquidity sweep what you do is simply go back to the one
minute time frame if you are looking at under 15 minute time frame right and you look for extreme
fair value gap and extreme fair value gap is around here you can see and i can use this whole candle
as my stop loss i will put my stop here and i can look to target
maybe this fair value gap here right there's this fair value gap here
or i could target this low here as well or i could target this low here as well so let's target
3.5 or eventually just to actually let's do this right so you can see we have our entry
after liquidity sweep and it just melts like a candle just goes down
and it hits our take profit right so look at the power of this thing right you
knew that your short term bias is bearish because of the SMT divergence
right and due to that you managed to win this trade it's really that simple you this is a very
very powerful tool that you can use so you can see that we had a a small divergence here
and over here you can see that we failed to create a higher high so this tells us only one thing
you could have traded this as well you know you could have looked for an a look for a
fair value gap around this level or maybe here and then you took a trade here but i recommend
as i always say recommend that you trade the pair or asset that sweeps the liquidity
that was a beautiful trade right as you can see it works with crypto as well if you're using
Bitcoin Ethereum right because they have similar movements as you can see so and also notice that
this was also an ABC strategy right so we had an ABC pattern and then we had a divergence oh sorry
a autoflow shift on Ethereum this tells us that the momentum is moving to the downside right
the Ethereum is now weaker in terms of being bullish right and this right here tells us there
was a liquidity sweep so we trade this and we write it down so this was example number two as you can
see it works with crypto as well and yeah guys let's move on to the another example
all right guys in this last example i'm going to show you how you can use three correlated
pairs together in order to trade so we have three correlated pairs like NAS 100
Dow Jones US 30 and S&P 500 right so you can look at three of these shots right three of these
you can you can look three of them right and look for the one that sweeps the liquidity
out of all these three right so you can see over here we have higher high higher low higher high
on NAS 100 so yes we swept the liquidity here over here you can see this right if i mayor from
this candle we could not make a we could not break this candle high here just like NAS 100 did right
you can clearly see that this candle on US 30 price failed to create a higher high
it just kept on going down this right here this exact reference candle this right here right
that swept the liquidity you move your pointer to that candle and look at this candle it did not
sweep the liquidity so we can trade this pair also if you look at NAS S&P 500 you can see that
S&P 500 also swept the liquidity right so you could trade this pair as well it's that simple
if this one pair is showing you know weakness in bullish direction you can trade the other pairs
in the same momentum right the bearish momentum because the autofel has not shifted into a bearish
trend so you can trade this and this as well so on NAS 100 after the liquidity sweep if you go
back to the one minute time frame we look for market structure shift and it happens right here
right it happened right here you can see so now when you have a fair value gap this big right what
you can do is go back to go to the higher time frame like this and it's going to show you another
fair value gap which is right here if I go to the three minute time frame all right so the
two minute time frame is this fair value gap and to further refine your entry what you can do is
you can use your Fibonacci from the start of the fair value gap to the end of the fair value gap
and you can take your entry from the 0.5 level yeah out of 10 times you're going to miss your entry
two times or three times but you're going to get a better entry right so we could take our entry
from here we can put our stop loss at the top of the fair value gap candle let me remove this
and let's wait for our target to be made all right so I think we have a target here which would be
this low here so let's see how this plays out all right so we get our entry right and if I
play this through you're going to see that we eventually go ahead and hit the take profit level
so this is 3.56 if you took a refined entry right if you took your entry from this fair value gap
and put it here this would have been a 1 to 2.28 which is really nice
so this is how you can use combinations and look for divergences and trade SMT guys
so I'm going to give you a little bit of tips that you can use
to even increase the win rate of the strategy right so what is as in my previous course videos I
have taught you guys premium and discount zones right so let's suppose that on a higher time frame
like the four hour time frame on a or a one hour time frame price direction is bullish right so
price is continuously making higher high high low higher high so when you have a
higher high high low and then you have a new higher high here you use your Fibonacci from that
new higher high right and you wait for price to come back into a discounted zone so now when the
price comes back into a discounted zone then you can look for SMT divergence around this level
on a 15 minute time frame right now that is going to increase your win rate by even more so
notice what I have explained here you use premium and discount with SMT and it's going to increase
the win rate all right if you are really serious about doing that because sometimes when I tell
people about using premium discount and using like a hard time frame confluence they just don't
want to do it right because they want easier way to trade but if you just implement this little
thing in in this strategy it's going to increase your win rate okay so you look at the hard time
frame so let's suppose that this is a one hour time frame or let's do four hour time frame okay
so price is making higher high high low higher high on a four hour time frame you know that the
the market structure is bullish now what do you do you wait for price to come back into a discounted
zone below a 0.5 level and then you look for smaller time frame SMT divergence so let's suppose
that you are looking at your USD here right so you're looking at your USD so on your USD you have
liquidity sweep and on DXY dollar index what you have is a
is a weakness all right so you have a weakness in DXY in terms of bullish so now this is going to
like oh my god this is going to be like the best entry that you can take okay so sorry guys I have
flew at the moment so yeah so you notice how we can implement PD areas premium discount
areas into our trading and it can work like a charm and let me think what comes what else comes
to my mind so make sure that you are you know trading during kill zone hours all right you can
go into the indicators tab and you can just type in iced kill zones right
and there are so many indicators that you can use so let's say iced kill zone boxes this one right
here and now you can trade uh within these kill zones right you should get the entry within this
time period so you can use like a high time frame structure PD array premium discount right
SMT divergence on 15 minutes right and some other time frame
um market structure shift um with fair value gap and you take your entry so this is like a whole
model that you can use to trade you can yeah of course you can use this as a standalone strategy
as well the SMT divergence but if you just add these things together because you know you gotta
do a little you gotta just add these things together and combine them together to create
your own strategy right like if every single person starts starts using the same strategy
right it just makes no sense because everyone is going to be a millionaire right so it's just
gonna destroy the economy and everyone is sitting with a billion dollars in their bank accounts right
there is no perfect strategy guys the perfect strategy is only when you back test it and just
you know change the strategy in your own way you just create that strategy in your own way
by back testing forward testing and you know just journaling each and everything
so I will end this lecture on SMT divergence right now and we are going to move forward with
our course videos if you have any questions about the strategy you can ask me in the discord
channel and if you didn't understand anything please re-watch the video and I'll see you guys in the
next video